empezó felicitando a su homólogo de
Colombia Gustavo Petro por su cumpleaños
número 63 vayan dijo también que
agradecía el trabajo que venía siendo
Colombia de Cara a la crisis migratoria
en Venezuela y en los esfuerzos por
recuperar la democracia y la Libertad en
Venezuela valores que el presidente
Gustavo Petro reconoció y resaltó como
valores que unen a Estados Unidos y a
Colombia en sus más de 200 años de
historia el presidente va y viene
también resaltó el trabajo que viene
siendo Gustavo Petro en cuanto a temas
climáticos y en cuanto a la paz dijo
también que Estados Unidos se quería
comprometer y seguir trabajando junto a
Colombia precisamente para tratar los
temas climáticos y seguir apoyando entre
otros el fondo por ejemplo de la
amazonía donde Estados Unidos ha
comprometido ya 500 millones de dólares
también dijo Joe biden que se compromete
con Colombia a seguir trabajando
precisamente los esfuerzos para lograr
la paz y los esfuerzos de paz en
Colombia
Cristóbal esas han sido las palabras de
biden que ha dicho también Gustavo Petro
Gustavo Petro Pues fue un poco más
extenso en las declaraciones que dio
después de la bienvenida que le envió el
presidente Joe biden en la casa blanca
Petro resaltó precisamente que la agenda
en común de los dos países es esa la
democracia la paz y la libertad que dijo
entre otras cosas el presidente de
Gustavo Petro que en los países de
América no han sido países que han
estado en guerra contra sí mismos en
general y que eso precisamente Debería
ser el foco de esfuerzo de el continente
para que otros países sigan Este ejemplo
resaltó sobre todo la importancia de
descarbonizar las economías dijo que por
un lado sí está el tema político está el
tema de la libertad y la democracia pero
que hay un trabajo muy grande en cuanto
a dejar que las economías del continente
sigan dependiendo del Carbón del
petróleo del gas y hacer una economía
mucho más dependiente energía se pierde
en ese sentido pues le hizo un llamado a
Estados Unidos que es uno de los países
que más emite gases de efecto
invernadero a que pues se trabajen de la
mano y sea Estados Unidos de de de de de
la mano también con Colombia ejemplos en
el mundo para descarbonizar estas
economías y agradeció obviamente a
Estados Unidos Pues el apoyo que ha
recibido en cuanto a la la crisis de
migrantes venezolana y pues se
comprometió a trabajar juntos recordemos
que Estados Unidos hace unos días de del
departamento de estado confirmó la
presencia de un enviado para los
diálogos que serán el próximo 25 de
abril el martes 25 de abril en Bogotá
para tratar el tema de la crisis
política en Venezuela